so we're talk about difference between
the web the internet the dark web and
the deep web but in order to talk about
all of these things and figure out why
they're different we need to start with
the basics of the web in the internet
because most people confuse those as
well as confusing the Deep Web and the
dark web and how the difference and
we're just going to try and figure all
that out today how they're separate so
we'll start off with the Internet what
is the Internet versus the web the
Internet is the physical connection of
all the computers that are joined
together across the world that's
probably the easiest way of looking at
it it started off with ARPANET in the
late 60s which was research agencies
getting together to connect their
computers from a long distance and this
is when computers were huge things in
massive rooms not little things we have
in our office and then that graduated to
the NSFNET which was the National
Science Foundation net which was all the
universities connecting together into a
kind of bigger network and then that
eventually in the start the 90s became
the Internet where they connected more
broadly to commercial networks as well
as research networks and when you
connect the Internet from your home on
your computer your computer simply
connects to the Internet and becomes one
of the many computers on the Internet
so what I have here is a picture of
several computers joined together in a
network tour over the computers the
circles and network is the lines between
them which is nice and then when you're
at home and you turn on your computer
and it connects to Virgin Media or
whoever you simply crop up on the
Internet and then you connects you to
one of the computers and suddenly you're
part of the whole big internet now every
computer on the internet has what's
called an IP address it's just an
address which is unique to that computer
on the Internet
and so even when your computer connects
to it you get your own IP address and if
you want to know where that is you can
just go to Google type in IP address in
Google helpfully tells you your IP
address is this I'm just imagining about
a thousand people doing that right now
all the computers just have this unique
address and it's like a sort code for a
bank is in every branch of a bank has a
unique sort code and when you ask to
send your money there it goes to that
address based on that sort code and so
every computer has this IP address on
the internet and it allows computers
know which exact computer they're
talking to when they're asking for
information so what is the web the web
is the software that runs on the
physical Internet so it's a software
layer essentially that is a way of
sharing information across all those
different computers the web is just one
type of software on the Internet and at
the types of software include email
exchange file transfer protocols where
you can send files to other computers
rather than download web pages from them
so it's just a type of software that
runs on the physical Internet and that's
an important difference that we're going
to get to when we get to dark web and
deep web so how do you view the web you
have something like Chrome or Safari and
these are web browsers and they just
know how to talk to the web to ask for
pages and to get things and so we have
these browsers on our computers in order
to view or access the web we also have a
lot of apps these days are they just
using the same sort technology yes yeah
so when your phone connects to the
Internet over 4G or 3G or via Wi-Fi it
is again it gets its own IP address and
apps just sending information across
that physical network not necessarily
using web software but using similar
communications to how web software
communicates with each other these are
down at the protocol levels and the
ports that they're connecting over
there's two key bits of the web which
make it work two bits of the software
one is URLs unique resource locators and
these are nice easy ways for you and me
to say which website we want to get to
or which webpage we want to see and so
this bit of software that helps the web
work is essentially a long list of if
you want to go to Nottingham AC dot UK
you ask the server and so it says I know
which physical computer that's stored on
is stored on one 28.24 3.8 0.167 I'm
just from down here and so actually in
your web browser you can either type in
nothing do I see the UK and go to the
website or you can type in 1.1 28.24 3.8
0.167 and it will show you the same web
page because the web page is stored on
that physical computer and so that's how
it knows which computers on the Internet
to ask for which web page you want to
see the next week you then need is an
HTTP server a hypertext Transfer
Protocol server got that right hopefully
and this is just the software that runs
on those
computers that says oh you want that
page sure here you go I'll give it to so
the Natyam desi DK server has an HTTP
server on it which says here you go
here's the page you wanted and sends it
to the person who's looking and so when
you type in HTTP colon slash slash wwm
title UK are basically saying I want to
use the hypertext Transfer Protocol to
look at the World Wide Web part of
Natyam Asil UK however you could use
different protocols to look at different
parts of not even like the file transfer
a bit one nice way of looking at the web
is that it's a whole lot of information
pages all of which say oh look there's
some interesting information on that
page over there and so you click on the
link which is the unique resource
locator or the URL and it sends you over
to that page and it goes off I know
another interesting page you might want
to look at go a look at this one you
click on it goes over there and that's
what hypertext is it's just text with
links in it and makes a hypertext so
that's when we all get sucked down the
rabbit hole yeah yeah if you follow
links forever and so the thing they say
about Wikipedia is that you're suddenly
viewing an endless number of links all
of which are very interesting following
each other forever and ever and ever and
suddenly five hours later you realize
you haven't had any dinner and it's
bedtime I've found out the thing you
won't no not at all there's four nice
examples and what makes the Deep Web
different from the web one is it stuff
behind passwords so any place that you
go we have to type in a password is a
place that Google can't go cuz it
doesn't have your password so it it
can't look at your bank information it
can't look at your probe